مستمرون معكم اذا في تغطيه تداعيات
الزلزال الى جانب ايضا ملفات اخرى في
الحصاد وفي ابرز العناوين
في اليوم الحادي عشر بعد الزلزال انقاذ
امراه ثانيه في كهرمان مراش بتركيا فرق
الانقاذ المحليه تؤكد مواصله عمليات البحث
رغم تضاؤل الامال وفي ظل جهود مكثفه لاواء
من فقدوا منازلهم جراء الزلزال نداء اممي
بجمع مليار دولار للمنكوبين والسلطات
التركيه تواصل حمله ملاحقه المقاولين
المخالفين بشروط البناء وتقول ان
التحقيقات ستشمل كل المتورطين
تاخر المساعدات يبقي الالاف في العراء
شمالي غرب سوريا في مقابله مع الجزيره
منسق الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه يقول
ان التمويل هو العائق الاكبر امام عمليات
الاغاثه ويؤكد الحاجه ل 400 مليون دولار
فورا والاتحاد الدوري للصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر يدعو الى تحرك دوري عاجل
[موسيقى]
ازمه الاعتقالات تتفاقم في تونس بعد
اعتقال المدير السابق لمكتب رئيس حركه
النهضه اتحاد الشغل يقولون التوقيفات
الاخيره لا تمت بصله الى المحاسبه وسعيد
يرفض الانتقادات الغربيه ويقول ان سياده
تونس فوق كل اعتبار وصحفيون ينظمون وقفه
احتجاجيه للمطالبه بوقف الاعتداءات عليهم
قبيل انعقاد القمه الافريقيه في اديس
ابابا وزير خارجيه مالي يؤكد للجزيره رغبه
بلاده في توسيع علاقاتها الدوليه وعدم
الاعتماد على شريك واحد تعليقا على
العلاقه مع فرنسا ووزيره خارجيه النرويج
تؤكد محاولات اوروبا لمواجهه مواصفاته
بتدخل روسي يقود استقرار القاره الافريقيه
عبر ميليشي
مشهد تتداخل فيه المشاعر والاحاسيس في
تركيا في ثنايا اعلان رسمي عن وقف البحث
عن ناجينا تحت الانقاض في خمس ولايات تطل
سيده في الثلاثين من عمرها لتعلن ان الامل
قائم وانقضت في ظلمه الانقاض اكثر من 200
وخمسين ساعه وهو رقم خارج حسابات العلم
حسب ما يقول الاطباء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حديث كارثه الزلزال دفع الامم المتحده الى
اطلاق نداء لجمع مليار دولار لمساعده اكثر
من خمسه ملايين شخص في تركيا ممن تضرروا
من الزلزال وقال مكتب الامم المتحده
لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه ان نداء الجديد
هدفه توفير الموارد لمنظمات الاغاثه
لتكثيف عملياتها ودعم جهود الاستجابه التي
تقودها الحكومه التركيه في مجالات تشمل
الامن الغذائي والحمايه والتعليم والمياه
والماوى واضاف المكتب وان اكثر من مليون
وسبعمائه الف لاجئ يعيشون في الولايات ال
11 المتضرره من الزلزال
وكانت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه قد
اعلنت ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى 36 الفا
ومائه وسبعه وثمانين في هذه الاثناء دخلت
الاستجابه للزلزال مرحله جديده كما قلنا
قبل قليل حيث اكدت مصادر في اداره الكوارث
للجزيره انتهاء عمليه البحث والانقاذ في
خمس ولايات هي ملاطيا وعثمانيه وكلس
وشارلي اورفا واضنها
هل تتراجع مشاهدك هذه في الايام القادمه
288 ساعه قبضتها هذه الفتاه تحت الانقاض
بكهرمان مرعش مناقضه هي وحالات كثيره
سابقه لتاكيدات مختصين بشان امكانيه
البقاء على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض طوال
الايام الماضيه تغلبت الحياه على الموت
على هذا النحو المؤثر في تركيا لكن بعد 11
يوما يعلن انتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ
في نصف الولايات المنكوبه وفق ما اكدته
مصادر في اداره الكوارث بينما تظل عمليات
البحث والانقاذ الجاريه في غاز عنتاب
وديار بكر واديامان وهاتاي
انتهاء عمليات الانقاذ يغير طريقه تعامل
السلطات مع الانقاض الهائله ويسرع عمليات
رفعها ما يعني البدء في عمليات اعاده
الاعمار بشكل اسرع وصولا لحل ازمه
المشردين لكن رفع الانقاض دون اعتبار لهدف
الانقاذ يقضي تقريبا على احتمالات العثور
على احياء في المناطق المعنيه ليست يسيره
مهمه اعاده الاعمار التي تنتظر السلطات في
سائر الولايات التركيه المنكوبه بالنظر
لحجم الدمار الذي اتى وفق شهادات على
قرابه نصف مدينه انطاكيا قلبي ولايتها تاي
اكثر الولايات تضررا وهي ليست وحدها في
ذلك فهناك مدن شديده التضرر كغاز عنتاب
وكهرباء على ان مهام رفع الانقاض القائمه
الان لن تقتصر على ما اسقطه الزلزال من
مباني فبحسب السلطات التركيه هناك حاجه
عاجله لهدم اكثر من خمسين الف مبنى في
الولايات المتضرره ما يعني ايضا امتدادا
لمهام رفع الانقاض التي ينتظر ان تبدا من
بعدها ما ترجوه الدوله من اعاده الاعمار
من مدينه شارلي اورفا مراسله الجزيره سلام
خضر سلام اريد ان اسال اولا المركز الاولى
متوسط
الزلازل يقول بانه رصد هزه ارضيه بقوه 4.7
درجات جنوبي تركيا هل لديكم اي معلومات
حول هذه الهزه الاخيره
المعلومات الوحيده المتوفره جلال نشرها
مركز الاورو متوسط ويبدو ان جمعيه افراد
المختصه بالطوارئ هنا في تركيا قالت ان
هزه مركزها انطاليا
[موسيقى]
يعني ضربت انطاكيا قبل قليل بدرجه وصلت
الى
5.1 درجه على مقياس اخترنا ننتظر مزيدا من
المعلومات والتاكيدات بخصوص هذا الامر
خاصه وان هناك بعض الولايات بحسب
المعلومات الاوليه لم تشعر بهذه الهزه نحن
هنا في شندي اورفا لم نشعر بارتدادات او
اي شيء من هذا القبيل حتى الان
والان هناك كما يتم ابلاغي من قبل الزملاء
ان مركز ابحاث الزلازل في جامعه
البوسفورت يتحدث عن زلزال بقوه 5.1 على
مقياس ريختر مركزه البحر المتوسط بانتظار
طبعا جلاء المزيد من المعلومات عن هذا
الموضوع ج لال طيب سلام طبعا شارلي اورفا
هي من المحافظات التي اعلن انتهاء البحث
عن ناجين فيها ما هي المرحله المقبله
بالنسبه
للاغاثه الايواء والفرق التي تعمل في
الاضرار في شان القرفه كانت محدوده مقارنه
بالاضرار التي وقعت في مدن كهرمان مراش او
في محافظات مثل كهرمان مراش هاتاي وايضا
اديمان الاضرار كانت محدوده ولكن
الاستجابه للزلزال كانت في المرحله الاولى
اغاثه العالقين تحت الانقاض المرحله
الثانيه عندما تم التحقق من رفع من عدم
وجود اي اشخاص تحت الانقاض احياء او اموات
بدات عمليه رفع الانقاض والتي ما زالت
جاريه بحسب السلطات الرسميه الرئيس التركي
قال ان عمليه رفع الانقاذ لن تنتهي قبيل
نهايه هذا الشهر لتبدا عمليه المرحله
الثالثه من الاستجابه للزلزال بدايه الشهر
المقبل وهي عباره عن اعاده اعمار المباني
التي تدمرت وايضا تدعيم المباني التي
بحاجه الى بعض التدعيم وما زالت قابله
للسكن على صعيد الاغاثه الامور تحسنت بشكل
كبير في الاولين كانت سلطات الاغاثه وايضا
المنظمات المختصه تعاني من مشاكل لوجستيه
لها علاقه بالاضرار المباشره بالزلزال
هناك الكثير من الطرق اصبحت غير سالكه لا
يمكن استخدامها لوقوع اضرار كبيره فيها
وايضا لوجود حجم نزوح كبير من قبل من
المناطق التي اتضررت بشده من الزلزال في
اليوم الثالث بدات الامور تسير بشكل
اعتيادي اكبر الاغاثه تصل للجميع تقريبا
مراكز الايواء باتت شبه جاهزه وهناك ايضا
المرحله سنشهدها في الايام القليله
المقبله وهي بدايه وضع مساكن جاهزه او ما
تعرف بالكرفانات
لواء السكان بدلا من بقائهم في الخيم خاصه
وان فصل الشتاء ما زال موجودا في تركيا
الان الجو يعني صحوا الى حد كبير ولكن
الشهر الثالث عاده يتوقع ان يكون ان تهطل
فيه امطار كثيره كما هي الحال في كل في
تركيا ولذلك السلطات تستعد لذلك بالبدء
بنشر بيوت جاهزه وفي جميع المناطق
المتضرره ايضا هناك مساله تحدث بها الرئيس
التركي واكدتها ايضا السلطات الرسميه بشكل
كامل ان الاهالي الذين يرغبون في ايجاد
مساكن لهم في ابنيه او عمارات خارج مناطق
تواجدهم او في المباني حيث يتواجدون والتي
لم يطالها الضرر السلطات التركيه ستقوم
بدعم هذه العائلات بمساعدتهم في دفع
ايجارات الوضع الاغاثي جيد ولكن طبعا هناك
المزيد من الاحتياجات مع مع مرور الوقت
وايضا
تبلور حجم الاضرار نحن الان مازلنا نتحدث
عن الاضرار المباشره التي اصابت البشر
بشكل كبير ولكن المرحله اللاحقه سيبدا
العمل في المنشات الاقتصاديه خاصه التي
تضررت شكرا لك سلام خضر في شانلي اورفا
نعود ونذكر بان هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه اعلنت عن هزه ارضيه بقوه خمسه
فاصله واحد تضرب ولايه هاتاي جنوب البلاد
وبانتظار معلومات اوفى عن هذه الهزه
الجديده انضم الينا من جنديرس في ريف حلب
مراسل الجزيره عمر الحوراني عمر لديكم اي
معلومات عن هذه الهزه الارضيه الجديده
المعلومه التي لدينا هو ان شعرنا بهذه
الهزه
والاخبار المتداوله ان حتى الان لا يوجد
اضرار الا ان يعني كثير من المناطق شعروا
بهذه الهزه شمال غرب سوريا وكانت هزه من
اكبر من اقوى هزات الارتداديه خلال الايام
الماضيه وهذه لذات مستمره وهنا ياخذنا
الحديث الى حاله الرعب المستمره لدى
الاهالي لدى اطفالهم من استمرار هذه
الهزات وهذا ما يجعل الكثيرين لا يعودون
الى المنازل التي هي قد تكون صالحه للسكن
يضاف لهم من هم مجبرين على عدم العوده الى
منازلهم كحال هؤلاء الموجودين في هذا
المخيم وهذا المخيم يعتبر هو واحد من كثير
من المخيم عمر التي تنتشر في المنطقه
تسمح لي سنعود اليك للحديث بالتفاصيل اكثر
عن جهود الاغاثه وهذه المرحله التي دخلت
فيها جنديرس ومناطق اخرى متضرره في سوريا
بعد قليل ارجو ان تبقى معنا سنعود اليك
عمر الحوراني في جنديرس
انطاكيا محمد يشيل منسق اعمال تاسيس
المخيمات للنازحين في جمعيه حجر الصدقه
التركيه ينضم الينا مرحبا بك
عندما نقول بان المرحله اصبحت مرحله جديده
وانتهى البحث عن ناجين في خمس ولايات ما
الذي يعني هذا
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الحالي
اننا نقوم باعمالنا كمنظمات مساعدات
انسانيه
ونحاول مساعده الناس
والان نوزع الطعام الساخن وما يحتوي شنو
هنا تشاهدون خلفي مطبخ
نستضيف فيه حوالي الف شخص
ونقدم علب من الطعامنا عده لتوزيع عليهم
واننا نعمل بكل جهودنا وكل الهيئات وهناك
تعاون كبير وتنسيق جيد
وشكرا جزيلا نشكر الجميع نشكر كل من قدم
يد المساعده
وساندتنا في هذه الكارثه وانا كشخص كشخص
تركي اشكر العالم كله اشكر كل ما اشكر قطر
وفاكستان واي دوله اخرى ساعدتنا نقدم لكم
الشكر الجزيل تقريبا كم عدد الذين تؤمنون
لهم الاحتياجات لاسيما اريتنا المطبخ قبل
قليل كم عدد المنكوبين الذين تهتمون بهم
وتؤمنون حاجيتهم في هذه المرحله في
انطاكيا
[موسيقى]
لا اسمعكم جيدا بسبب
الطريق السريع الذي نحن الى جانبه وفيه
حركه سيارات ولكن نحن نقدم الطعام الساخن
لحوالي الف شخص
نبذل كل قصائى وقصار جهودنا لمساعدتهم
دائما قبل قليل تابعنا بان هز ارضيه ضربت
هاتاي بقوه 5.1 هل هناك اي تاثير على
عملكم تاثير نفسي ربما على من تساعدونهم
لهذه الهزات الارتداديه المتكرره في هذه
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
[موسيقى]
لم تحصل لدينا هزه ارتداديه اليوم لكن
سبقا شاهدنا ذلك
طيب
اعود واذكر بان هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه هي التي اعلنت عن وقوع هزه هزه
ارضيه بقوه 5.1 في ولايه جنوبي البلاد على
كل حال نشكر السيد محمد يشيل منسق اعمال
تاسيس المخيمات للنازحين في جمعيه يبدو
انه عاد الاتصال كنا فقدنا الاتصال معه
ولكن عاد الينا طيب سيد محمد يشيل اريد ان
اعرف الى جانب ما تقدمونه الان ما هي
الاولويات بالنسبه للمنكوبين نعلم ان هناك
تخوف الان من انتشار الامراض تامين مياه
الشرب الى اخره ما هي الاولويات بالنسبه
لكم
لاغاثه المنكوبين المتواجدين في انطاكيا
[موسيقى]
لدينا الافنا الناس من وزاره الصحه
التركيه موجودون معنا
ولم يحصل شيء هنا في محافظه انطاكيا ولكن
في الواقع كانت هناك
هزه كبيره جدا
ولدينا برنامج جيد للعمل
شكرا محمد يشيل في انطاكيا وانت منسق
اعمال تاسيس المخيمات للنازحين في جمعيه
حجر الصدقه التركيه شكرا لك
وعلى ضوء هذا المشهد قال وزير العد التركي
ان السلطات تحقق مع مئتين وخمسه وخمسين
مقاولا وان الدوله ستحاسب المقصرين على
اكمل وجه كما اشار الى ان الملاحقه ستشمل
الموظفين الذين يثبتوا تواطؤهم هذا وتستعد
السلطات التركيه لهدم مدينه نورداغ التي
ضربها الزلزال بشكل كامل وبناء مساكن
جديده ومؤقته للمتضررين وتسليمها في غضون
اسبوعين في منطقه امنه من الزلزال برسل
الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن زار المنطقه
التي تجري فيها اعمال البناء ووقف على
تقدم الاشغال فيها
هذه المدينه بحسب المعلومات التي حصلنا
عليها سيتم هدها بشكل كامل والانتقال الى
خطه جديده من اجل ايواء مواطنيها
السيناريو الابرز هو بناء بيوت وخيم
وايجاد خيم وحاويات معدنيه لكن في هذه
المنطقه التي نقف فيها ربما يكون هناك
اجابه للسؤال حول كيف ستكون المرحله
المقبله في هذا المكان هذه الشركه المحليه
بدات في بناء بيوت هذه البيوت من طابق
واحد وهي من الطوب وهي تبني على مساحه
تقدر بحوالي هنا في هذا المشروع على الاقل
اتحدث مساحه تقدر ب 200 واربعين الف متر
يعني 240 دونم وهذا المشروع ليس وحده هناك
مشروع اخر في منطقه مجاوره مجموع هذه
المساحه في هذه المنطقه فقط يزيد على
400 الف متر مربع هذه البي هنا ستكون من
طابق واحد الان تجري عمليه البناء سيسلم
هذا المشروع بحسب مسؤوليه الشركه الذين
تحدثت اليهم قبل هذه المقابله يفترض ان
يسلم 525 منزلا من هذه البيوت حتى نهايه
الشهر الحالي اي خلال اسبوعين وهذه البيوت
ستكون مجهزه بشكل كامل ليس فقط البناء
ستكون مجهزه بما يحتاج تحتاج هذه البيوت
في داخلها لتكون جاهزه للسكن وذلك خلال 15
يوما القسم الثاني من المشروع سيكون في
مرحله لاحقه نلاحظ ان هنا عملي استمرار
عمليات البناء لتسليم هذا المشروع في فتره
زمنيه سريعه طبعا هذا المشروع ليس وحده
هنا في هذا المكان هناك عده مشاريع مشابهه
في مناطق اخرى المساحات التي نتحدث عنها
تزيد ربما عن
مئات الدونمات وهذه المساحه هي اراض
خصصتها الدوله من اجل بناء بيوت كهذه وفي
هذه البيوت
هذه البيوت ستكون خيارا ربما مبدئيا من
اجل اسكان المواطنين الاتراك الذين هم
موجودون في تضررت بيوتهم في مدينه نورداغ
لان هذه المدينه سيتم هدمها بالكامل ومن
ثم دراسه ارضها من جديد لمعرفه ما اذا
كانت ستكون صالحه للبناء مجددا ام لا
محلوله
[موسيقى]
وفي سوريا تحولت العديد من الساحات العامه
وحقول الزيتون في شمال البلاد الى ما يشبه
الماوى المؤقت لعشرات الالاف من الاسر
التي شردها الزلزال هناك ورغم الجهود التي
تبذلها جهات اغاثيه محليه ووصول بعض
المساعدات الدوليه فان الشكوى لا تزال
حاضره من وجود فجوه كبيره بين الاحتياجات
العاجله للمنكوبين هناك وما يقدم لهم اذ
لا تزالوا اعداد كبيره منهم تفترش العراء
بعد مرور عشره ايام على وقوع الزلزال
وتقول منظمات دوريه ان توفير مياه الشرب
وخدمات صرف صحي اصبح امرا ضروريا لمنع
انتشار الامراض
جانبيه قال المنسق الانساني الاممي بسوريا
مهند هادي ان الامم المتحده تواجه تحديات
جامه في اغاثه المنكوبين وان نقص التمويل
هو العائق الاكبر الذي يواجه المنظمه
الدوريه واضاف المنسق الانساني الامومي
بسوريا في حديث للجزيره ان الامم المتحده
اعلنت حاجتها بشكل عاجل الى 400 مليون
دولار لتجاوز تداعيات الزلزال بينما تحتاج
اربعه مليارات دولار لمساعده الشعب السوري
بسبب تدعيه الحرب وما تمر به البلاد
بعض الدول الغربي الغربيه تواصلت معنا
وهم في نيه وفي صدد تقديم المساعدات
الماليه لكن 400 مليار 400 مليون دولار هو
مبلغ كبير واضف الى ذلك سيدتي نحن بحاجه
للعمل الانساني الاخر في سوريا اللي هي
الاستجابه
لظروف
متطلبات الحرب ونتائج الحرب والازمه اللي
يمر فيها باقي سوريا نحن نهاجئ بحاجه الى
اكثر من 4 مليار دولار
نعود اذا الى عمر الحوراني المتواجد في
جنديرس عمر كنت بدات تشرح لنا وضعيه
المنكوبين في هذه الخيم والمخيم حيث ان
تفضل
نعم هي وضعيه قاسيه وليلى قاسيه اخرى
وتتوالى الليالي القاسيه التي تمر على
سكان هذا المخيم وهذا المخيم هو صوره
لجميع المخيمات التي تنتشر في المنطقه حيث
نشاهد هنا الكثير من هذه الخيام
المنتشره هنا المنتشره
اذا هي الخيام المنتشره والشكوى المستمره
من من سكان هذه المخيمات ماذا يقول الذين
يطلبون المزيد من المزيد من المساعدات هذه
الخيام غير مجهزه هذه الخيام لا يوجد فيها
مدافع لا توجد فيها تجهيزات كعازل يعزل
بروده الارض عن
من يسكن بهذه المخيمات هناك مطالبات
مستمره لايجاد خيام افضل من هذه الخيام
التي حضرت على عجل وهناك ايضا مطالبات
للتجهيز مطالبات للغذاء نتحدث عن حاجه
المنطقه الى قرابه 60 الف وجبه بشكل يومي
نتحدث عن حاجه المنطقه للمحروقات هي حاجه
مستمره هذه الخيام كما شاهدتم ان كنتم
تشاهدون عن قرب هي اقمشتها رقيقه جدا لا
تقي من يذكرها البرد ودرجات الحراره جدا
نحن يعني جهزنا انفسنا الا اننا نشعر ببرد
شديد جدا فما بالك بالاشخاص الذين غادروا
منازله منازلهم جراء الهزه وهم لم يتحضروا
بشكل جيد
بالبسه وبالاغطيه ومع نقص بدخول هذه
المساعدات نتحدث عن عشرات الحافلات ونتحدث
هذا اليوم دخل
قافله من مقدم من دوله قطر عبر معبر
الحمام هذه القافله المهم فيها انها تحمل
معدات طبيه مهمه لا سيما المعدات الخاصه
بغسيل الكلى وهي تحتوي ايضا على فرن
لصناعه الخبز ويتواجد فيها اغذيه ولكن هذه
المساعدات المقدمه هي لا تتناسب مع حجم
المعاناه التي يعيشها الاف النازحين نتحدث
عن الاف
الذين شردوا جراء هذا الزلزال الان
هذه حركه الهواء كل ما نرصده وقاسيه
تستطيع ان تشاهد من خلال الصوره عند تعرض
هذا المخيم لحركه هواء فهذه الخيام هي غير
غير مثبته بالشكل المطلوب غير مثبته
بالشكل المناسب كما تشاهدون اذا اثناء
بثنا لهذا لهذا اللايف هناك حركه رياح
قويه
عصفت بهذا المخيم وزادت من معاناه
المشردين هنا كما نشاهد وكما ترصد لكم
الصوره هذه الصوره هذه الحاله الماساويه
التي يعيشها سكان هذه المخيمات لاسيما
انهم بالالاف مع مع دمار شمل قراء اكثر من
1700 مبنى وايضا هناك اكثر من 5000 مبنى
اي للسقوط حتى من هم لديهم مساكن يعني
صالحه للسكن هم لا يستطيعون
العوده اليها بسبب الخوف وهم بحاجه الى
البقاء ضمن الخيام وذلك
ليتجنبوا هذا الخوف
طبعا من ابرز الاحتياجات الان هي ماء
الشرب ما الذي تخبرنا عنها في هذا المخيم
البدائي جدا في هذه المنطقه في جنديرس هل
هناك مياه شرب في ظل خوف من تفشي الامراض
في غياب مياه الشفا
عمر يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال بعمر حوراني
المتواجد في جنديرس بيريف حلب شكرا لك على
كل حال عمر حوراني مراسل الجزيره افاد بان
قافله جديده من المساعدات الاغاثيه
القادمه من الامم المتحده وعدد من
الشاحنات المقدمه من الجمعيات الخيريه
وصلت الى معبر باب الهوى شمال غربي سوريا
وكانت قافله مساعدات قطريه قد وصلت الى
معبر الحمام على الحدود التركيه السوريه
تمهيدا للدخول الى الشمال السوري لاغاثه
المتضررين من الزلزال
في الاثناء يستمر دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه التي تقدمها الامم المتحده عبر
معبر باب الهواء للمتضررين من الزلزال
شمال غربي سوريا التقرير التالي يسلط ضوءا
على هذه المساعدات
المزيد من المساعدات الدوليه تصل الى باب
الهوى كل يوم تتسلمها المنظمات الشريكه
للامم المتحده لتوزيعها في المناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال شمال غرب سوريا لا
يتحدث سائق الشاحنات عن اي صعوبات تعترضهم
وتحمل الشاحنات مساعدات طبيه وخياما ومواد
غذائيه
سيتم تجهيز مواد غذائيه اساسيه وكذلك
بطاريات وفرش وخيام اليوم تم استلام قرابه
400 خيمه من صندوق قطر التنميه ست وصلت
على على الطائرات القطريه سيتم ان شاء
الله
ادخالها في اليوم الثاني لداخل السوري
وانشاء مخيم للعوائل التي هي في العراق
بسرعه يبني المتطوعون خيمه وينتقلون الى
اخرى كذلك تعمل المنظمات الشريكه مع الامم
المتحده على ايواء العائلات في مخيمات
وتزويدها بوسائل التدفئه كي لا تبقى في
العراء وسط البرد لكن المتضررين من
الزلزال توزعوا على مناطق متفرقه هنا في
منطقه جسر الشغور اقيم لهم مركز ايواء وسط
المخيم يحاول سكان المخيم تقديم العون لهم
لكن ما يشغل بال فاطمه هو ابقاء ابنتي هذا
فئتين عندما يغيب الاب للبحث عن مسكن افضل
طلعنا معها العالم كان مطر ونحن بيتنا اكل
صاروخ
وبعد ما صارت الهزي زاد بزياده هر الحجر
والاولاد ما عرفنا كيف طلعناهم بالليل
ومطر وليل جابونا لهون
وبعدها ما معنا الاغراض ولا شيء جبنا بس
الاولادي
بدنا صوبه بدنا حطب اسفنجات ما طلعنا شيء
ابدا معنا
وامام قسوه الاحوال ينشغل الجميع عن
المعاناه التي يعيشها كبار السن جراح
عميقه يعانيها المتضررون من الزلزال
يقولون انما يساعدهم على تجاوز الالم هو
اعاده اعمار بيوتهم وليست اي مساعدات اخرى
صاحب الخلف الجزيره ريف ادلب
نقوم حاليا بتقييم امكانيه اقامه مستشفى
ميداني داخل سوريا وهو امر لازم في هذا
الوقت ما رايته في حلب هو ازمه تلو الازمه
فالزلزال ضرب منطقه مدمره اصلا لذلك بدانا
بحشد الجهود الدوليه لاغاثه تلك المناطق
اكثر المشاكل التي تواجهنا هي ازمه الوقود
والكهرباء في حلب كان هناك تفش للكوليرا
قبل الزلزال توفير الماء والادويه من
القضايا الملحه في هذا الوقت علينا ايضا
ان نولي اهتماما للبنيه التحتيه فهذه ازمه
متفاعله
من بيروت الدكتور حسام فيصل رئيس وحده
الازمات والكوارث في الاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
لمنطقه الشرق اوسط وشمال افريقيا دكتور
حسام كيف ترون الاستجابه للاحتياجات
الكبيره في شمال غرب سوريا
مساء الخير بدايه الاحتياجات ضخمه وضخمه
جدا وتزداد مع مرور الوقت بسبب ظروف
المناخ ضعف البنيه التحتيه وايضا التناقص
الموارد الموجوده للمؤسسات والمنظمات
المختلفه للقيام بعمليات الاستجابه وفي
هذا السياق اود ان اؤكد على قيامه الاتحاد
الدولي للجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر اليوم بزياده حجم التمويل المطلوب
للاستجابه للاحتياجات المتفاقمه الناجمه
عن كارثه الزلزال الى 200 مليون فرنك
سويسري للوصول الى مليونين ونصف شخص من
الاشخاص الذين تضرروا بشكل مباشر كارثه
الزلزال مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار الاحتياج
الضخمه ما قبل كارثه الزلزال وتفاقمت بسبب
كارثه الزلزال
طبعا السيد تشابجين اشار الى انها
مرحله طويله الامد ما الذي يترتب على هذا
بدايه عندما ننظر الى مرحله الطوارئ من
خلال تقديم خدمات الايواء المياه والاصحاح
خدمات الصحه النفسيه خدمات اخرى تتعلق
بمرحله الطوارئ يجب ان لا نغفل عن اهميه
النظر الى المدى الطويل كيف نساعد هذه
المجتمعات المتضرره على استعاده سبل
العيشه على العوده الى اعمالها ان امكن
على قدرتها على العوده الى منازلها بشكل
امن ان امكن على دعمها ايضا ودعم صمود هذه
المجتمعات دعم عوده الاطفال الى المدارس
مدارسهم دعم خدمات التعليم دعم الخدمات
البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه التي ستمكن من
هذه المجتمعات المحليه من الاستمرار في
الصمود يوجد ايضا نقاط اخرى بدات تظهر
الخدمات القانونيه كمثال يقوم زملائنا في
منظمه الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري بالعمل
على هذا الموضوع الاوراق الثبوتيه
المحتاجه لهؤلاء الاشخاص للقدره على
الوصول لبعض الخدمات التي نقوم بامس
الحاجه
اسمح لي ان اؤكد على نقطه مهمه جدا ان
التضامن الدولي والدعم الدولي يجب ان
يستمر ويستمر لفتره طويله ويجب ان لا
يتوقف هذا الدعم بغياب اخبار كارثه
الزلزال والاحتياجات عن شاشات التلفزه
وعناوين الاخبار
ولكن تابعنا قبل قليل مع مراسلنا عمر
حوراني في جنديرس هذا
المخيم البدائي جدا خيم يعني لا تصمت حتى
امام قليلا قليلا من من الهواء
الاستجابه على المديين القصير
والمتوسط لا تزال متواضعه جدا ما هي
المبررات
بدايه نقص التمويل هو من احدى المعوقات
الاساسيه وذكرت في بدايه الحديث عن اهميه
التضامن الدولي والدعم الغير المشروط هو
شيء اساسي جدا الصعوبات اللوجستيه على
الارض نقص الوقود الاثر السلبي جدا
للعقوبات على العمل الانساني هذه كلها
معوقات تعيق العمل الانساني السهل والسلس
على الارض ناهيك ان المناطق المتضرره هي
مناطق تفشى فيها سابقا الكوليرا يوجد
انهاك قوي جدا في البنيه التحتيه فهي كلها
عوامل تؤثر على صعوبه الوصول وتقديم
الخدمات بانسب شكل للفئات المتضرره شكرا
لك الدكتور حسام فيصل رئيس وحده الازمات
والكوارث في الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
[تصفيق]
الله
ما بين شي عنهن لحتى الان
[موسيقى]
وضعنا كتير كتير
الى تونس التي تشهد حمله اعتقالات غير
مسبوقه منذ 2011 اليوم اكد المحامي سمير
ديرو للجزيره اعتقاله فوزي كمون المدير
السابق لمكتب رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي واشار الى انه يجري التحقيق معه
في مقر احدى الفرق الامنيه المختصه بتونس
العاصمه
بجانبه اتهم الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد جهات
لم يسميها بالتباكي على حريه التعبير رغم
انها ماجوره من قوى لا تزال تعمل في
الظلام بحسب تعبيره وشدد على ان تونس دوله
مستقله وان العمل تحت رئاسته يجري في ظل
احترام كامله للقانون وان سياده البلاد
فوق كل اعتبار
سيادتنا فوق كل اعتبار
وفكره الحريه
استبطناها قبلهم بكثير
فلينظر في تاريخهم قبل ان ينظروا في
تاريخنا ولينظر في واقعهم قبل ان يتحدثوا
عن الاوضاع في تونس
لسنا تحت الاستعمار او الحمايه او
الانتداب نحن دوله مستقله
ذات سياده
ونعلم جيدا ما نقوم به في ظل احتراما كامل
للقانون
قال الامين العام المساعد للاتحاد التونسي
للشغل ومتحدثه الرسمي سامي الطاهري ان
التوقيفات الاخيره لا تمت للمحاسبه بصله
وان الاتحاد يرفضها في ظل وجود اسباب
واهيه وملفات فارغه واضاف الطاهري خلال
ندوه دراسيه ان الاتحاد ماض في تحركاته
الرافضه لكل اعتداء على الحريات والحقوق
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الا انه متمسك
بعدم التصادم مع السلطه رغم محاولاتها
المتعدده لاستدراج الاتحاد نحو الصدام
هذا ونظم صحفيون تونسيون وقفه احتجاجيه
بساحه الحكومه للمطالبه بالكف عما وصفوه
بالاعتداء على الاعلاميين وللمطالبه
بالغاء المرسوم 54 الذي يعتبرونه قامعا
لحريه التعبير وخطرا على العمل الصحفي
ياتي هذا التحرك في وقت تتصاعد فيه
الانتقادات للسلطات في البلاد بعد ملاحقه
اعلاميين على خلفيه عملهم الصحفي
خطوه تصعيديه تعقبها تحركات اخرى
في يوم غضب وتجنب من اجل التصدي للمخططات
التي تستهدف قطاع الاعلام المنهك اصلا
بازماته الماليه وغياب التشريعات الضامنه
لحقوق الصحفيين بل والتنصل الرسمي من
تطبيق اتفاقات سابقه خاصه تلك المتعلقه
بالمؤسسات الاعلاميه العامه او تلك التي
صدرت في اعقاب الثوره السيطره السلطه
السياسيه على الاعلام العمومي
وكيف حاولت التلفزه العموميه المموله من
دافئ الضرائب الى التلفزه راي واحد وصوت
واحد وتقوم بالدعايه السوفيتيه للنظام
الحاكم هناك ايضا مساله حريه صعبه
والتقافات والاحالات المتكرره
مدير اذاعه موزاييك نور الدين بوتار اذاعه
موزاييك الخاصه ذات الانتشار الواسع في
تونس اوقف مديرها العام منذ ايام في قضيه
لا تعرف تفاصيلها الا بتصريح محاميته التي
اكدت ان من بين اسباب التحقيق معه والخط
التحريريه للمؤسسه هو تحدي كما اي تحدي
اخر نحن نعيشوه كتحدي للمهنه وكتحدي
للايداع كتحدي
لرساله رساله المهنه في الجهه المقابله
يضحك الرئيس قيس سعيد جميع الاتهامات
المتعلقه بانتهاك الحقوق والحريات
ومن بينها حريه الصحافه والتعبير وهل تمت
ملاحقه اي صحفي من اجل عملا يتعلق
بالصحافه
للاسف
اكاذيب
واراجيف يثير المرسوم الرئاسي المتعلق
بمكافحه الجرائم المتصله بانظمه المعلومات
والاتصال مخاوف جديه من اطراف عده نظرا
الى تضمنه عقوبات زجريه قاسيه
ويتنزل وفق منتقديه في اطار الطريق الرسمي
على الصحفيين والناشطين تسر نقابه
الصحفيين التونسيين على مواصله تحركاتها
دفاعا عن الحقوق والحريات
وتصديا لما تعتبره خطرا دائما يستهدف مهنه
السحافه
وتساندها في ذلك منظمات حقوقيه ومدنيه في
وقت تعد فيه السلطات نفسها ضامنه لحريه
الراي والتعبير سيفو عليك الجزيره
تونس
اقشر الموضوع مع ضيفينا من تونس السيد
بالحسن اليحياوي الكاتب والمحلي السياسي
ومن صفاقس الحبيب بوعقيله الكاتب والمحل
السياسي مرحبا بكم
وصحفي كيف ترى ما يقول صحفيون بانه اعتداء
على حريه الصحافه وعلى صحافينا لمجرد
ارائهم المخالفه للسلطه التونسيه
في الحقيقه ان يكون الامر كما وصف وبهذه
الطريقه طبعا هو امر لا يمكن القبول به
ولا يمكن المساس من المكتب الوحيد تقريبا
الذي تحقق في 2011 وهو الحريات السياسيه
سواء تحدثنا عن حريه التعبير او تحدثنا عن
حريه التنظم او غير ذلك كل ممارسه تذهب في
هذا الاتجاه هي قطعا غير مقبوله ولا يمكن
الدفاع عليها او تبريرها باي شكل من
الاشكال ولكن بعض الوقائع احتمل اكثر من
قراءه واكثر من فهم حتى فيما يتعلق
بالاذاعه الخاصه
السؤال الذي يبقى مطروحا الى حد هذه
اللحظه هل ان هذا المدير العام اوقف لصفته
بوصفه مدير عام هذه المؤسسه ان
اوقف وتوجه اليه التهم لشخصه اي
لشخص هو
يعني بماذا عن صفته كصحف او كمدير لهذه
الاداره الخاصه من ناحيه الثانيه الصحافه
دائما مكانه تحت المعاناه وهذه المعاناه
من جهات عده ليست من جهات الرسميه
المتعلقه بالقوانين او متعلقه بالنظم
واللوائح المنظمه لعمل الصحافه بل ايضا
من المؤسسات الصحفيه ومن يتحكم فعلا في
هذه المؤسسه
سيد الحبيب اين الشبهات السياسيه في
التوقيفات الاخيره للرئيس قيس سعيد
ما هي كلها شبهات سياسيه يعني كل
الموقوفين تقريبا باستثناء بعض الاسماء
التي ارادها السيد قيس سعيد ان يخلط بها
الاوراق كلها اسماء سياسيه عبرت عن
معارضتها لانقلاب 25 جويليه بعضها عبر عن
هذه المعارضه منذ اليوم الاول للانقلاب
وبدا يعني يتم استهدافهم منذ اشهر اقصد
بذلك القيادات الاساسيه في حركه النهضه
والضعف القيادات في جامعه الخلاص وقيادات
في ائتلاف الكرامه وغيرها
وبعضهم ممن عبروا
يعني اعتراضهم على مسار 25 جويليه
واسموه بالانقلاب فبدا استهدافهم سواء
كانوا سياسيين او نقابيين او حتى اعلاميين
واخرهم بطبيعه الحال
مدير اذاعه موزاييك التي يعرف عنها انه
لديها برنامج معروف في الظهر بشكل يومي هو
برنامج ميدي شوك
ويتبين بوضوح ان خط التحرير في هذا
البرنامج هو تقريبا خط نقدي معترض بشكل او
باخر لدى محلليه الرئيسيين
سيد بلحسن دائما الرئيس السعيد يشير الى
الافعال دون تسميه الفاعل يعني دائما
يتحدث عن مخربين
متامرين المتباكين على حريه التعبير ولكن
لا يشير دائما الى الفاعل كيف تفهمون هذا
النهج وهذا الاسلوب من الرئيس قيس سعيد
لا هو منذ البدايه يعني الرئيس قيس سعيد
يحيل كل الافعال هذه الافعال التي التي هي
تهم في حقيقه الامر الى المجهول
وخياب الجهه الرسميه التي يمكن من خلالها
ان نفهم الى من يومئ رئيس الجمهوريه اساسا
يترك الباب مفتوحا وعلى مصرعيه
لتاويل كلمات الرئيس بل وايضا لنشر
الاشاعه الى حد هذه اللحظه لم تفهم رئاسه
الجمهوريه ضروره ان يكون هناك ناطق رسمي
ان يكون هناك من يتكلم ويقدم التفسيرات
وتبريرات حتى يقطع دابر الاشاعه والتهويل
التي اصبحت مهيمنه والتي سببت حاله يعني
حاله من الحده الغير منصوفه داخل المجتمع
التونسي وداخل كل الفاعلين حقيقه في
المجتمع التونسي السياسه الا انكشافيه
التي يصر رئيس الجمهوريه على اعتمادها
فيما يتعلق بالتواصل والاعلام
اعتقد انه في هذه اللحظه لم يعد لها مبرر
قد تفهم هذه السياسه اثناء حاله الاستثناء
ولكن بالانتخابات التشريعيه والمجلس
النواب الجديد اعتقد انه لم يعد هناك مبرد
لذلك ولا يجب على رئيس الجمهوريه ان يسمح
بكل هذا الايهام وبكل هذا الغموض الذي
يسمح للاخرين بان يؤولوا كلام رئيس
الجمهوريه وايماءات رئيس الجمهوريه الى
غير يعني الى غير ما يريده هو فعلا ما
يسبب هذه الحاله التي ذكرناها وللاسف هو
امر غير مقبول لا من رئاسه الجمهوريه ولا
حتى ايضا من الحكومه التي اتخذت نفسها
الناجي فيما يتعلق بالتواصل سيد الحبيب
كيف تفهمون تشديد الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل على تمسكه بما سماه عدم التصادم مع
السلطه في هذه المرحله كيف تفهمون هذا
الكلام في هذه المرحله الحساسه الان التي
تمر بها تونس
يعني هو مجرد كلام تكتيكي دعنا نقول حتى
لا يظهر الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل بانه
ربما يتبنى السرديه السياسيه التي تعبر
عنها الان الطبقه السياسيه
باعتراضها على انقلاب 25 جويليه ولكن
البيان الذي اصدره مكتب التنفيذي للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل يوم امس كان بيانا
واضحا وصارما ودقيقا حيث انه لم يتوقف عند
تاكيد ان الاتحاد سوف
يناضل من اجل الحريه النقبيه بل ذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك بانه
سيقف صدا منيعا في مواجهه كل استهداف
للحريات العامه التصور ان بيان الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل يوم امس انها تقريبا
كل امكانيه
التقاء سياسي او تحييد للاتحاد العام
التونسي لشغل من المعركه السياسيه التي
فتحها الان السيد قيس سعيد
خصومه الاتحاد الان هو جزء رئيسي من معركه
سياسيه واجتماعيه يبدو فيها ان السيد قيس
سعيد هو ضد الجميع يعني وفي مواجهه الربيع
وبالتالي كلام احد قيادي اتحاد الشغل يبقى
في حدود يعني ربما
اللغه الدبلوماسيه والعلاقات العامه
الاكثر شكرا السيد الحبيب بوعقيله في
صفاقس وسيد بن حسن اليحياوي في تونس
العاصمه
يعرض برنامج الجزيره التحقيقيه ما خفي
اعظم مساء غد الجمعه تحقيقا جديدا من تونس
يكشف تفاصيل مثيره تتعلق باحداث امنيه
كبيره عصفت بالبلاد خلال السنوات الاخيره
ولا تزال طي الكتمان ما خفي اعظم حصل في
تحقيقه الجديد الذي يحمل عنوان تونس
الايادي الخفيه على تسريبات ووثائق حصريه
تميت لثاما عن شخصيات نافذه متورطه في هذه
الاحداث ولم تحاسب حتى اليوم التحقيق الذي
يقدمه تامر المسحال التقى شخصيات مرتبطه
بتلك الاحداث في ظل التحديات الامنيه
والسياسيه التي تشهدها تونس هذه الايام
اذكروا ان المشهد التونسي يعيش حاليا
استقطابا حادا على وقع اتهامات رئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد بتصفيه حسابات سياسيه
عبر القضاء مع معارضيه وفتح ملفات ضدهم في
الوقت الذي يصمت عن ملفات اخرى لا تزال
تثير كثيرا من الجدل وعلامات الاستفهام
حولها ما خفي اعظم تونس الايادي الخفيه
ياتيكم مساء غد الجمعه عند العاشره وخمس
دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه على شاشه
الجزيره ومنصاتها المختلفه
[موسيقى]
اختتمت في العاصمه الاثيوبيه اديس اعمال
المجلس التنفيذي للاتحاد الافريقي لبحث
التوافق بشان جدول الاعمال والقرارات التي
سترفع لقمه الرؤساء الافارقه المقرره يومي
السبت والاحد المقبلين وبحث اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه الاستعداد والتحضير للقمم
الجانبيه التي ستعقد غدا الجمعه والتي
ستناقش قضايا امنيه في القاره من بينها
الملف الليبي اضافه الى اصلاح مجلس الامن
الدولي وحصول القاره الافريقيه على مقعدين
دائمين فيه
الوجود الروسي في القاره الافريقيه
والنفوذ الدولي هناك كان حاضرا على هامش
الاجتماعات حيث قال وزير خارجيه مالي عبد
الله جيوب للجزيره ان لبلاده حريه اختيار
شركائها الخارجيين وذلك في تعليق على
انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه من مالي والوجود
الروسي في البلاد
الامر بسيط بالنسبه لنا بحسب ما قال رئيس
مالي لدينا ثلاث قواعد ذهبيه لتفاعلنا مع
المجتمع الدولي اولا احترام سيادتنا
واحترام خيارنا الاستراتيجي الذي تقوم به
حكومتنا في اختيار الشركاء والثالث هو
التاكد من مراعاه المصالح الحيويه لمالي
في جميع عمليات صنع القرار
جانبها اكدت وزيره خارجيه النرويج اهميه
التعاون الاوروبي مع دول افريقيا
لمواجههما وصفته بتدخل الروسي في شؤون
القاره وفي تصريحات للجزيره على هامش
مشاركه بلادها كمراقب في اجتماعات وزراء
الخارجيه الافارقه بقدس ابابا اتهمت
الوزيره ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه بالقيام
بدور في عدم استقرار الاوضاع الامنيه
بالقاره
مجموعه الروسيه تساهم بشكل مباشر في عدم
استقرار بعض الدول في هذه المنطقه نعتقد
انه يجب علينا تعزيز التعاون عندما يتعلق
الامر بالاحتياطات الامنيه ومواجهه
التهديدات الارهابيه لهذا اعتقد انه تجب
زياده التعاون بين الدول الاوروبيه والدول
الافريقيه لتفادي سيطره وتدخل روسيا في
افريقيا
في التقرير التالي نتعرف على شكل المنافسه
الاوروبيه الروسيه في افريقيا
على موقعها الجغرافي وثرواتها يتنافس
الكبار روسيا الصين الولايات المتحده
واقوى الدول الاوروبيه يحاول الجميع تامين
حركاته التجاريه في العالم عبر المياه
المشاطئه للقاره السمراء لكن الجميع كذلك
يسعى لاستغلال حاجات هذه القاره لتثبيت
نفوذ عسكري طويل الامد يعزز التفوق
الجيوسياسيه لكل طرف صحيح ان الاعين
الاجنبيه التفتت قديما الى افريقيا الا ان
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعادت الى الواجهه
عناوين المنافسه في العالم خصوصا المنافسه
الاوروبيه الروسيه في افريقيا
كانت فرنسا راس الحربه في الهيمنه
الاوروبيه على افريقيا سيطرت على نصف
القاره تقريبا بعد عام
1885 تقلصت هذه السيطره شيئا فشيئه منتصف
القرن الماضي امتلكت فرنسا مئه قاعده
عسكريه تقلصت الى سبع قواعد فقط وبدا هذا
الوجود يتلاشى حتى بات مهددا بالكامل رغم
ذلك تظل اوروبا حاضره في القاره في فبراير
من العام الماضي عقدت القمه السادسه بين
الاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي اعلنت حينها
خطه استثماريه على مدى سبع سنوات لا يزال
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحظى بالحصه الكبرى من
الشراكه التجاريه مع افريقيا اكثر من ثلث
التبادل التجاري الافريقي الخارجي
عين روسيا بصيره هنا في نوفمبر 2019
استضاف الرئيس بوتين اول قمه روسيه
افريقيه الهدف تامين صفقات تجاريه ومشاريع
للطاقه وعقود عسكريه كانت روسيا اكبر مصدر
للاسلحه في المنطقه تنامت هذه الصادرات
اربعه واربعين في المئه بين 2017
و21 تنامي معها الوجود العسكري الروسي في
القاره في ليبيا ومالي وافريقيا الوسطى
وبوركينا فاسو اعتمدت على ميليشيا فاجنا
الذراع العسكريه غير الرسميه لموسكو
الحديث يطول كثيرا عن الوجود الامريكي
والصيني والمنافسه المحمومه بين بيجين
وواشنطن على مساحه النفوذ في القاره
السمراء هكذا يتزاحم الكبار على تثبيت
اقدام في افريقيا على المدى البعيد تتعالن
صوت الشعبيه برفض هذه المنافسه تم من يرى
ان التواتر الاجنبي على القاره لا يخدم
الا مصالح الدول الكبرى فحسب
ايضا
مدير معهد كونفوشيوس في جامعه جوهانسبورغ
والخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه مرحبا بك
كيف نفهم هذا التحول لدول في القاره
الافريقيه نحو روسيا بدل اوروبا
افريقيا هي حاليا
تجتذب عددا كبيرا من الدول الهامه في من
العالم ونظرا لجوانب الجغرافيه السياسيه
والتوترات الكثيره التي
تشهدها القوات الغربيه بقياده ما يتم
المتحده اذ انه لديهم سياسات عسكريه
واقتصاديه يبدو انها تبعد نفسها عن الصين
وروسيا التوترات في الحقيقه تزداد يوما
بعد اخر وافريقيا
اصبحت بشكل متزايد مركز هذا التنافس
واعتقد انه
بقمه التي ستحصل فيها عطله نهايه اسبوع
هذه سنجد عددا من الوفود من كل هذه القوه
العظمى وفود سياتون للاتحاد الحديث مع
القاده الافارقه لعظم موقفهم وتعزيز
مواقفهم في القاره الافريقيه ولكن ما هو
اكثر اهتماما هو ان ال الاوروبي الذي
بالبيان الذي قدموه فيما يتعلق بالتنافس
مع روسيا في القاره الافريقيه ما هي مالات
هذا التنفس عفوا التنافس الروسي الصيني من
جهه كما اشرت الاوروبي من جهه اخرى وما
تدعيته المحتمله على القاره الافريقيه
في الوقت الحالي هذا التنافس لم يصل الى
مستوى المستوى الذي كان سائدا في الحرب
البارده ولكن هناك بعض المؤشرات الكثير
القلق
خاصه في شمال وفي غرب افريقيا حيث نجد ان
روسيا
تؤثر على عدد من الحكومات الافريقيه
والمجموعات العسكريه التي استولت على
السلطه
النفوذ الفرنسي عن هذه القاره وقد شاهدنا
ذلك في مالي وفريق الوسطى جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى وايضا شاهدنا النشاطات وتحركات
روسيه في عدد من نزاعات الاخرى سواء في
اثيوبيا او ليبيا وفي كثير من الدول
الاخرى وهذا طبعا يزيد القلق
واشنطن بشكل كبير ومتزايد وكذلك الاتحاد
الاوروبي نظرا لان فرنسا هيعض مهم في
الاتحاد الاوروبي دكتور طيب مثلا ما الذي
يقدمه روسيا والصين لحكومات افريقيه عجزت
عنه دول في اوروبا مثل فرنسا كما ذكرت
اعتقد انما شهدناه هو الاختلاف في
المقاربه
فالعالم الغربي والقوى الاوروبيه بشكل خاص
ينقلون اوروبا وانتقلنا اوروبا بشعور بان
افريقيا هي ساحتهم الخلفيه فهي بالنسبه
لهم مستعمراتهم السابقه خاصه فرنسا
واسبانيا ايضا وكذلك بريطانيا وايضا لدينا
عدد من الدول مثل ذلك المانيا الذي لديهم
نفوذ متنوع مختلف في تقارن الافريقيه ولكن
فرنسا بالذات ما زالت تسيطر وتستخدم
السياسات
الاستعمار الجديد في الدول الافريقيه وهذا
ما
زاد من زادت النفوذ الروسي عسكريا
وبالتالي فعلا نوع المساعدات التي تقدمها
روسيا للقاره الافريقيه فهي بشكل رئيسي في
مجال السلاح العسكري والتدريب القوات
العسكريه وفي حين ان الصين لديها
مقاربه مختلفه تماما فيتفكر بجانب اقتصادي
ببناء البناء التحتيه اضافه ان هذا من
البلدين لديهم نفوذ في الامم المتحده وفي
مجلس الامن
وبالتالي ميلان الى الدفاع
قضايقه واحده هل يمكن للقاره الافريقيه ان
تستفيد من هذا التنافس الروسي الصيني
الاوروبي
وتنويع الشراكه في في دول القاره
الافريقيه باقتضاض لو سمحت
الخوف الاكبر بالنسبه لافريقيا انه لو ان
هذا التنافس ادى الى زياده استيراد
الاسلحه والى توترات المباشره هو النزاعات
الصغيره في القاره الافريقيه كما كان
الحال اثناء الحرب البارده ولكن الامر كله
يعتمد على الاتحاد الاوروبي
الافريقيه وكيف القدره على كيفيه اداره
هذه التنافس فلو ان التنافس ادى الى
المزيد من الاستثمارات ماليه وبناء البنى
التحتيه وعدم مزايا ضمن
شركات عده الاطراف فلذلك سيكون مفيدا
لافريقيا كما ان افريقيا بدات تستفيد من
تجربه اسيا وامريكا اللاتينيه لتعرف شكرا
لكن كيف ان الدول الاخرى تدير هذا التنافس
بين القوه العظمى شكرا الدكتور ديفيد مدير
معهد كونفوشيوس في جامعه جوهانسبورغ شكرا
لك
راس الساعه اليكم تذكيرا بابرس عناوين
الحصاد
هزه ارضيه بقوه خمس درجات تضرب مناطق في
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا انقاذ امراه ثانيه
في كهرمان مراش بعد 11 يوم من الزلزال وفي
ظل جهود ايواء من فقدوا منازلهم جرائم
الزلزال نداء اممي لجمع مليار دولار
للمنكوبين بتركيا
تاخر المساعدات يبقي الالاف في العراء
شمالي غرب سوريا في مقابله مع الجزيره
منسق الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه يقول
ان التمويل هو العائق الاكبر امام عمليات
الاغاثه ويؤكد الحاجه لاربع مئه مليون
دولار فورا والاتحاد الدوري للصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر يدعو الى تحرك دوري عاجل
ازمه الاعتقالات تتفاقم في تونس بعد
اعتقال المدير السابق لمكتب رئيس حركه
النهضه اتحاد الشغل يقولون التوقيفات
الاخيره لا تمت بصله الى المحاسبه وسعيد
يرفض الانتقادات الغربيه ويقول ان سياده
تونس فوق كل اعتبار وصحفيون ينظمون وقفه
احتجاجيه للمطالبه بوقف الاعتداءات عليهم
موبايلا انعقاد القمه الافريقيه في اديس
ابابا وزير خارجيه مالي يؤكد للجزيره رغبه
بلاده في توسيع علاقاتها الدوليه وعدم
الاعتماد على شريك واحد تعليقا على
العلاقه مع فرنسا ووزيره خارجيه النرويج
تؤكد محاولات اوروبا لمواجهه ما وصفته
بتدخل الروسي يقود استقرار القاره
الافريقيه عبر ميليشيايفر
اذا افادت هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
نهزه ارضيه بقوه
5.1 على مقياس ريختر ضربت ولايه هاتاي
جنوبيه البلاد من جهه اخرى افادت وكاله
السوريه بوقوع هزه ارضيه شعر بها اهالي
دمشق وحلب واللاذقيه ومحافظات اخرى
بعد قليل سنتواصل مع الدكتور احمد ملاعبي
استاذ علم البيئه والجيولوجيا في الجامعه
الهاشميه في عمان لنسال اكثر عن هذه الهزه
التي وقعت في الوان متحده اطلقت نداء لجمع
مليار دولار لمساعده اكثر من خمسه ملايين
شخص في تركيا ممن تضرروا من الزلزال وقال
مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق شؤون الانسانيه
ان نداء الجديد هدفه توفير الموارد
لمنظمات الاغاثه لتكثيف عملياتها ودعم
جهود الاستجابه التي تقودها الحكومه
التركيه في مجالات تشمل الامن الغذائي
والحمايه والتعليم والمياه والماوى واضاف
المكتب ان اكثر من مليون و700 الف لاجئ
يعيشون في الولايات ال 11 المتضرره من
الزلزال
وكانت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه قد
اعلنت ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى 36 الفا
ومئه وسبعه وثمانين فادي الاثناء دخلت
الاستجابه للزلزال مرحله جديده كما قلنا
في الساعه الاولى من الحصاد حيث اكدت
مصادر في اداره الكوارث للجزيره انتهاء
عمليات البحث والانقاذ في خمس ولايات هي
ملاطيا وعثمانيه وكلس وشارلي اورفا واضنه
هل تتراجع مشاهدك هذه في الايام القادمه
278 ساعه قضتها هذه الفتاه تحت الانقاض
بكهرمان مارش مناقضه هي وحالات كثيره
سابقه لتاكيدات مختصين بشان امكانيه
البقاء على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض طوال
الايام الماضيه تغلبت الحياه على الموت
على هذا النحو المؤثر في تركيا لكن بعد 11
يوما يعلن انتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ
في نصف الولايات المنكوبه وفق ما اكدته
مصادر في اداره الكوارث بينما تظل عمليات
البحث والانقاذ الجاريه في غاز عنتاب
وديار بكر واديامان وهاتاي وكهربان مرعش
انتهاء عمليات الانقاذ يغير طريقه تعامل
السلطات مع الانقاض الهائله ويسرع عمليات
رفعها ما يعني البدء في عمليات اعاده
الاعمار بشكل اسرع وصولا لحل ازمه
المشردين لكن رفع الانقاض دون اعتبار لهدف
الانقاذ يقضي تقريبا على احتمالات العثور
على احياء في المناطق المعنيه ليست يسيره
مهمه اعاده الاعمار التي تنتظر السلطات في
سائر الولايات التركيه المنكوبه بالنظر
لحجم الدمار الذي اتى وفق شهادات على
قرابه نصف مدينه انطاكيا قلبي ولايه هاتاي
اكثر الولايات تضررا وهي ليست وحدها في
ذلك فهناك مدن شديده التضرر كغاز عنتاب
وكهرباء على ان مهام رفع الانقاض القائمه
الان لن تقتصر على ما اسقطه الزلزال من
مباني فبحسب السلطات التركيه هناك حاجه
عاجله لهدم اكثر من 50 الف مبنى في
الولايات المتضرره ما يعني ايضا امتدادا
لمهام رفع الانقاض التي ينتظر ان تبدا من
بعدها ما ترجوه الدوله من اعاده الاعمار
من اسطنبول السيد امريكيا رئيس قسم
العلاقات الخارجيه في هيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه التركيه سيد
ما الذي يترتب على مرحله ما بعد الاعلان
عن انتهاء البحث عن ناجين في خمس ولايات
تركيه
طبعًا انه هناك في بعض المدن مع انتهاء
عمليه البحث بالانقاذ
هناك ايضا المدن هناك اليستمر هذه العمليه
البحث والانقاص حتى نحن حاليا وصلنا
260 ساعه ولكن قبل ساعتين نحن وصلنا هناك
واحد حيا من تحت الاوقات والان ايضا ينتظر
هناك
وجود اناس
نحن
نتمنى ان يكونوا هناك اشخاص ينتظروننا تحت
الانقاذ وما زال في اماكن التي يستمر
عمليه البحث الانقاص ان هناك في هذه
الاوقات صعب جدا ان نصل الى الاشخاص حيا
ولكن يستمر هذه الامر ونحن نصل الى
الاشخاص حيا
[موسيقى]
ما صعوبه المرحله المقبله لاسيما في
الولايات التي تم الاعلان بانتهاء البحث
عن ناجين فيها
طبعا ان هناك خاصه
ما
نحن سننتقل مثل هذه البلدان الى المرحله
الايوائيه نعم هناك نحن يجهز
الخيم واغلبيه الناس حاليا تحت الخيام
ولكن هناك الهدف ان يكون
اللجوء الناس الى
نسمى بالعربيه الحاويات شكرا لا نريد ان
يكون مع الاسف الصوت متقطع جدا شكرا لك في
اسطنبول رئيس قسم العلاقات الخارجيه فائت
الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه
هذا وتمكنت فرق الانقاذ في مدينه كهرمان
مراش من انتشار سيده عمرها 30 عاما وهي
على قيد الحياه بعد بقائها لمده
258 ساعه تحت الانقاض في اليوم الحادي عشر
للزلزال وتم نقل الناجيه الى المستشفى
لتلقي العلاج وافاد ناطق باسم فريق
الانقاذ ان العثور على السيده ضاعف الامال
في العثور على نجينا اخرين وان اعمال
البحث ما زالت مستمره رغم تضاؤل الامال
يذكر ان فرق الانقاذ تمكنت صباح اليوم من
انقاذ شابه عمرها 18 عاما في كهرما مرش
ايضا وسط توقف اعمال البحث والانقاذ في
مدن اخرى
طه احد نجينا من زلزال كهرما مراش بقي شاب
عالقا تحت الانقاض طويلا قبل ان يتم
انقاضه عاش لحظات ظن فيها ان لا احد سوف
ينتشله قصه طه يرويها لمراسله الجزيره
سلام خضر من اديمان
نجت هذه البلده من لحظات رعب زلزال كهرمان
مراش لكن الماسي التي تسبب بها وصلت الى
كول اوف هووك فتشنا عن احد الناجين ووجدنا
طه
يريد يشتم سقطت على الارض وشعرت انني في
تابوت لم اكن استطيع التنفس تساقط الركام
وعلقت تحتها رفعت راسي لادرك ان منزلنا قد
نهار
يرفض طه دخول المنزل باتت الخيمه منزله
يخشى اي باغته زلزال اخر
علقت في مكان ضيق جدا جسمي محشور تحت
الركام بالكاد كنت اتنفس احسست انني على
وشك الموت بمرور الوقت استنفذت قواي عندها
قلت انني لن اخرج حيا فقررت ان اسجل رساله
لعائلتي
بقي طه طويلا تحت الركام حتى اعتقد انها
النهايه وانه سيموت وهو في السابعه عشره
من عمره فسجل هذا الفيديو
لا تزال الارض تهتز اسال الله ان يغفر
ذنوبي ان بقيت على قيد الحياه فلدي الكثير
لاحققه ما زلت في مقتبل العمر
قدمي اليمنى لا تتحرك
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
انه زلزال ثامن اشعر بالارتجاج
نشطها وقتل الزلزال عمه مع زوجته واولاده
ليدفن في مقبره البلده في اليوم الحادي
عشر للكارثه
لا يذهب طه الى اديمان المدينه التي خسر
فيها الكثير نحن سنذهب اليها
سنفتش عن المبنى الذي علق طه تحت انقاضه
توجهنا الى اديمان ومن بين مئات المباني
وجدنا منزل طه تحول الى اطلال
سيحتاج طه الى وقت طويل ودعم نفسي ليتخطى
ما مر به ولا يمكن لاي منا ان يدرك شعور
العالقين تحت الانقاض الذين دفنوا احياء
لايام او لساعات قبل انتشالهم
وربما ما يبقى في الذاكره فقط كلمه طه
يعني
ياتينا الموت بخته
سلام خضر الجزيره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه بان هزه ارضيه
بقوه 5.1 على مقياس ريختر ضربت ولايه
هاتاي جنوب البلاد كما افادت وكاله سانا
السوريه بوقوع هزه ارضيه شعر بها اهالي
دمشق وحلب واللاذقيه ومحافظات اخرى وربما
نضيف بحسب وسائل الاعلام محليه في لبنان
ايضا مناطق عده شاعره شعرت بهذه الهزه من
عمان الدكتور احمد ملعبي استاذ علم البيئه
والجيولوجيا في الجامعه الهاشميه ينضم
الينا دكتوره الازياء هل هذه هزات
اعتياديه بعد زلزال مدمر
نعم رغم ان شدتها
ارتفعت قليلا من خمسه واحد بالعشره وهذه
على مقياس نخسر على الحد الفاصل بين
الزلزال الخفيف والزلزال المتوسط يعني
زلزال خفيفه
لكن متوقع متوقع الهزات الان وصلت 4000
وربما تستقر الصفيحه نحتاج من سته الى
ثمان شهور واحيانا عام فمثل هذه الهزات
متوقعه ولكن لا تكون بحجم الزلزال الرئيسي
الذي وصل سبعه وثمانيه بالعشره على مقاس
اشرت الى قوتها قوه هذه الهزه 5.1 على
مقياس ريختر هل لهذا دلالات دكتور
لان الطاقه لا زالت موجوده وان
لا زالت في حاله ارتداد وليس تصادم
هذا السبب هو السبب الرئيسي التموج هذه
الصفيحه او الصفيحه العربيه
مع الصفيحه
تموج الصفيحه العربيه امام الاناضوليه
تسبب مثل هذه المشاكل والهزات الارتداديه
سريعا اذا سمحتي بسبب ضيق الوقت لو كانت
هزه بوقت عادي ربما لا تاثير كبير لها
ولكن في ظل هذا الزلزال والدمار الكبير
الحاصل هل هناك مخاطر من هكذا هزات
ارتداديه باقتضاب شديد لو سمحت
المشكله هي الخوف من المباني التي تكسرت
بالزلزال الرئيسي ولم تنهدم مثل هذه
الاجزاء بقوه خمسه قد تؤدي الى هدمها او
ردمها مره اخرى فلذلك هنالك مخاطر تفريغ
للسكان حتى من اي مباني قريبه من هتان او
من كهرمان او
العشر ضروريه جدا شكرا الدكتور احمد
ملاعبي استاذ علم البيئه والجيولوجيا في
الجامعه الهاشميه في عمان
تحولت العديد من الساحات العامه وحقول
الزيتون في شمال سوريا الى ما يشبه الماوى
المؤقت لعشرات الالاف من الاسر التي شرها
زلزال هناك ورغم الجهود التي تبذلها جهات
اغاثيه محليه ووصول بعض المساعدات الدوليه
فان الشكوى لا تزال حاضره لوجود فجوه
كبيره بين الاحتياجات العاجله للمنكوبين
هناك وما يقدم لهم اذ لا تزالوا اعداد
كبيره منهم تفترش العراء بعد مرور عشره
ايام على وقوع الزلزال وتقول منظمات دوليه
ان توفير مياه الشرب وخدمات صرف صحي اصبح
امرا ضروريا لمنع انتشار الامراض
جانبه قال المنسق الانساني الاممي بسوريا
مهند هادي ان الامم المتحده تواجه تحديات
جامه في اغاثه المنكوبين وان نقص التمويل
هو العائق الاكبر الذي يواجه المنظمه
الدوريه واضاف في حديث للجزيره ان الامم
المتحده اعلنت حاجتها بشكل عاجل الى 400
مليون دولار لتجاوز تداعيات الزلزال بينما
تحتاج لاربعه مليارات دولار لمساعده الشعب
السوري بسبب تدعيه الحرب وما تمر به
البلاد
بعض الدول الغربيه تواصلت معنا
وهم في نيه وفي صدد تقديم المساعدات
الماليه لكن 400 مليار 400 مليون دولار هو
مبلغ كبير واضف الى ذلك سيدتي نحن بحاجه
للعمل الانساني الاخر في سوريا اللي
هي الاستجابه
لظروف
متطلبات الحرب ونتائج الحرب والازمه اللي
يمر فيها باقي سوريا نحن نهاجه بحاجه الى
اكثر من اربعه مليار دولار
اشير الى ان هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه تعلن ارتفاع عدد القتلى قتلى
الزلزال في المناطق التركيه الى 38 الف
واربعه واربعين قتيلا حتى الان بطبيعه
الحال ونعود ونذكر بانه تم الاعلان عن
انتهاء البحث عن ناجينا في خمس ولايات وقد
وصف الامين العام للاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه
الصليب والهلال الاحمر جاغان تشابه جينا
الازمه في مناطق شمال سوريا بانها طويله
الامد وطلب المجتمع الدولي بالتحرك الفوري
لاحتواء اثار الزلزال في سوريا واكد عدم
قدره اي منظمه على الاستجابه للكارثه
منفرده
نقوم حاليا بتقييم امكانيه اقامه مستشفى
ميداني داخل سوريا وهو امر لازم في هذا
الوقت ما رايته في حلب هو ازمه تلو الازمه
فالزلزال ضرب منطقه مدمره اصلا لذلك بدانا
بحشد الجهود الدوليه لاغاثه تلك المناطق
اكثر المشاكل التي تواجهنا هي ازمه الوقود
والكهرباء في حلب كان هناك تفش للكوليرا
قبل الزلزال توفير الماء والادويه من
القضايا الملحه في هذا الوقت علينا ايضا
ان نولي اهتماما للبنيه التحتيه فهذه ازمه
متفاعله
هذا واثار مراسل الجزيره قافله جديده من
المساعدات الاغاثيه القادمه من الامم
المتحده وعدد من الشاحنات المقدمه من
الجمعيات الخيريه وصلت الى معبر باب الهوى
شمال غربي سوريا وكانت قافله مساعدات
قطريه قد وصلت الى معبر الحمام على الحدود
التركيه السوريه تمهيدا للدخول الى الشمال
السوري لاغاثه المتضررين من الزلزال
وفي هذه الظروف يقدم متطوعون سوريون خدمات
اغاثيه طارئه للنازحين المتضررين من
الزلزال ويقول المتطوعون ان تاخر وصول
المساعدات الدوليه للمتضررين دفعهم لتطريم
مساعدات بامكانات وجهود محليه لسد الحد
الادنى من الاحتياجات العاجله
غير بعيد عن موقع الزلزال
تضميض لجراحم النجو من الماسه
سماح سوريا متطوعه بالدفاع المدني تعمل مع
رفاقها متنقله من موقع الى اخر
تداوي جرحا وفي النفس جرح لا يظهر رغم
مصابنا بان فقدنا بيوتنا من وفقدنا احد
المتطوعات معنا بالمركز توجهنا توجهنا
لعمليات البحث والانقاذ وبعد ما انتهينا
توجهنا لمراكز الايواء وعم نساعد الناس
يلي متضررين بالزلزال
وجه اخر اوجه التكافل الاجتماعي بين
السوريين يظهرون
فتاخر المجتمع الدولي في تقديم العون
لمنكوبي الزلزال دفع مجموعه من المتطوعين
الى انشاء مطوخ ميداني
هي محاوله يسد ثغره وافساح المجال
للمكوبين الى النمه جراح اخرى تركها
الزلزال لما شفنا اثار الدمار في مدينه
جنديرس وشفنا فرق الانقاذ تواصل الليل
بالنهار بعملها من اجل انتشال الاحياء خطر
بان نقوم بمطبخ ميداني في مدينه جنديرس
لانه ما حدا بلشان فيهم اكيد
بالاطعام الليلي يعني خصوصا ما حدا راح
يفضى لهم فخطر ببالنا المطعم المطبخ
الميداني وكان دعمه طبعا من مبادرات اهليه
محليه
ولان كثيرا ممن شردهم الزلزال باتوا بلا
ماوى حتى الان ياتيهم العون محليا هذه
المره بل شو تركيب شباب
فالاولويته لعبد الله ومن معه
هي تامين خيام المشردين احنا لا منظمه ولا
جمعيه ولا مساعدات دوليه هاي كلها جهود
فرديه وشخصيه وجهودها لنا واصدقائنا واللي
قلبهم علينا عم يساعدونا هاي المساعدات
فنحن امكانياتنا على قدنا
حاله تكافل اجتماعي يظهرون في انتظار
تجاوب دولي مع منطقه عانت ويلات الحرب قبل
ان تصبح منقوبه بالزلزل هذه الخيمه هي ما
استطاعت الجهود المحليه تمنه قد لا توفر
الدفء والراحه المنشوده لساكنيها لكنها
اصبحت حلما لكثير من منكوب الزلزال بعد
تاخر وصول مساعدات دوليه
عمر الحوراني الجزيره من مدينه جنديرس في
حلب
في وقت اعلنت فيها السلطات تركيا توقف
البحث عن ناجين في خمس ولايات وكاله
الاناضول تشير الان الى انقاذ طفل بعد
انقض 260 ساعه تحت الانقاض في انطاكيا
برايتها تاي جنوبيه تركيا طبعا سنعرض
عليكم الصور فور توفرها ينضم الينا من
مدينه سلقين في مدينه ادلب احمد بكرو
الباحث الميداني في وحده تنسيق الدعم في
الشمال السوري سيد احمد ما اسهامات
المنظمات المحليه في عمليات الاغاثه
والدعم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته واسعد
الله مساءكم بكل خير
اخي العزيز بالنسبه للشمال غرب سوريا
بالاصل هي منطقه منقوبه من حيث
البنيه التحتيه والخدمات ومن حيث ارتفاع
نسبه الفقر خلال فتره الحرب من 2011 حتى
الان ومن حيث طبعا عدد السكان الموجودين
وبالاضافه الى ويلات الحرب حاليا نحن امام
كارثه انسانيه حقيقيه ولابد هنا من ان
تعلن عن تلك المنطقه منطقه منكوبه انسانيه
لانها تفتقد الى ادنى مقومات الحياه من
حيث الغذاء والماوى وحتى الطبابه وحتى
المحروقات بالاضافه الى الخدمات الاوليه
فنحن بشكل عام مناطق ريفيه
ومتسعه الانتشار وبالتالي المنظمات تعمل
على تشكيل مئوي او ماوى عام
يحتاج الى وقت طويل حتى يتم تقديمه او
تامين
سيد احمد بكر كما اسلفنا نقلا عن وكاله
الاناضول التركيه انقاذ طفل عمره 12 عاما
بعد ان قدم 260 ساعه تحت الانقاذ هذه
الصور التي وصلتنا الان
لعمليه انتشال الطفل بعد مرور
260 ساعه قضاها تحت الانقاض في منطقه
انطاكيا بولايه هاتاي جنوبي تركيا طبعا
كما اشرنا قبل قليل ايضا ولايه هاتايا
التركيه شهدت قبل حوالي ساعه من الان هزه
ارضيه ارتداديه قوتها خمسه فاصله واحد على
مقياس رختر اذا جهود الاغاثه مستمره لليوم
الحادي عشر على التوالي وهي تثمر بانتشال
طفل
بعد ان قضى مئتين وستين ساعه تحت انقاض
هذا المبنى المهدم تماما هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا وهي قبل قليل لعمليه انتشال الطفل
من قبل رجال الاغاثه والمسعفين في منطقه
انطاكيا بولايه هاتاي
[موسيقى]
طيب نعود اليك صيد احمد بكر الباحث
الميداني في وحده تنسيق الدعم في الشمال
السوري مفهوم بان المنطقه الان تمر بكارثه
كبيره والامم المتحده اعترفت بانها تاخرت
بايصال المساعدات واغاثه المنكوبين اطلعنا
على الجهود الداخليه للمنظمات المحليه كيف
ساهمت في التخفيف ولو قليلا من هذه
الكارثه الانسانيه
طبعا نبدا في عمليات الانقاذ اغلب عمليات
انقاذ التي جرت في مناطتنا بجهود محليه
ومن هنا نستغل لشكر طبعا الابطال ابطال
الدفاع المدني الذين يعملون ليل نهار
والذين بالفعل اثبتوا جداره وامكانيه
العمل لذلك
المجتمعات المحليه في انقاذ اكبر
عدد الارواح وبالتالي
فيما بعد
انتشار الجثث المتبقيه تحت الالقاب
في الشق الاخر هناك مبادرات مجتمعيه قام
بها بعض التجار بعض ابناء المجتمعات
المحليه في الوصول الى الناس في المزارع
المحيطه في المدن والبلدان بالاضافه الى
بعض المنظمات التي تعمل بالشراكه احيانا
مع منظمات اخرى قامت بتوزيع بعض المبالغ
الماليه كاستجابه طارئه ولكن طبعا لا يمكن
ان تغطي هذا العدد الكبير من الاسر انا
اعطيك مثال بسيط
احمد الان بعد دخول المساعدات بكميات تقول
الامم المتحده انها ليست كافيه ولكنها
تسرع بادخال المساعدات ما هو دور المنظمات
المحليه وخاصه في وحده التنسيق والدعم ما
هي اليات ايصال هذه المساعدات للمحتاجين
نحن نعمل من خلال وحده تنسيق الدعم وحتى
بالتعاون مع كل من هو موجود على الارض في
بناء قاعده بيانات دقيقه وواضحه لكي نصل
الى اكبر عدد ممكن من المتضررين فيما
يتعلق بتامين الماوى بالاضافه الى تامين
الغذاء بالاضافه الى قيام
بالاحصائيات عن البيوت المدمره والبيوت
المتضرره
طيب شكرا لك السيد احمد بكرو الباحث
الميداني في وحده تنسيق الدعم في الشمال
السوري مجتمعنا من مدينه سلقين في ادلب
وتحول الى تونس الان التي تشهد حمله
اعتقالات غير مسبوقه منذ الفين واحد عشر
اليوم اكد المحامي سمير ديرو للجزيره
اعتقال فوزي كمون المدير السابق لمكتب
رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي واشار الى
انه يجري التحقيق معه في مقر احدى الفرق
الامنيه المختصه بتونس العاصمه
بجانبه اتهم رئيسه التونسي قيس سعيد جهات
لم يسميها بالتباكي على حريه التعبير رغم
انها ماجوره من قوى لا تزال تعمل في
الظلام بحسب تعبيره وشدد على ان تونس دوله
مستقله وان العمل تحت رئاسته يجري فضل
الاحترام كامل للقانون وان سياده البلاد
فوق كل اعتبار
سيادتنا فوق كل اعتبار
وفكره الحريه
استبطناها قبلهم بكثير
فلينظر في تاريخهم قبل ان ينظروا في
تاريخنا ولينظر في واقعهم قبل ان يتحدثوا
عن الاوضاع في تونس
لسنا تحت الاستعمار او الحمايه او
الانتداب نحن دوله مستقله
ذات سياده
ونعلم جيدا ما نقوم به في ظل احتراما كامل
للقانون
قال الامين العام المساعد للاتحاد التونسي
للشغل ومتحدثه الرسمي سامي الطاهري ان
التوقيفات الاخيره لا تمت للمحاسبه بصله
وان الاتحاد يرفضها في ظل وجود اسباب
واهيه وملفات فارغه الطاهر اضاف خلال ندوه
دراسيا الاتحاد ماض في تحركاته الرافضه
لكل اعتداء على الحريات والحقوق
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الى انه متمسك
بعدم التصادم مع السلطه رغم محاولاتها
المتعدده لاستدراج الاتحاد نحو الصدام
هذا ونظم صحفيون تونسيون وقفه احتجاجيه
بساحه الحكومه للمطالبه بالكف عما وصفوه
بالاعتداء على الاعلاميين وللمطالبه
بالغاء المرسوم 54 الذي يعتبرونه قامعا
لحريه التعبير وخطرا على العمل الصحفي
ياتي هذا التحرك في وقت تتصاعد فيه
الانتقادات للسلطات في البلاد بعد ملاحقه
اعلاميين على خلفيه عملهم الصحفي
خطوه تصعيديه تعقبها تحركات اخرى
في يوم غضب وتجند من اجل التصدي للمخططات
التي تستهدف قطاع الاعلام المنهك اصلا
بازماته الماليه وغياب التشريعات الضامنه
لحقوق الصحفيين بل والتنصل الرسمي من
تطبيق اتفاقات سابقه خاصه تلك المتعلقه
بالمؤسسات العالميه العامه او تلك التي
صدرت في اعقاب الثوره السيطره السلطه
السياسيه على الاعلام العمومي
وكيف حاولت التلفزه العموميه المموله من
دافئ الضرائب الى التلفزه راي واحد وصوت
واحد وتقوم بالدعايه السوفيتيه للنظام
الحاكم هناك ايضا مساله حريه صعبه
والايقافات والاحالات المتكرره
ايقاف مدير اذاعه موزاييك نور الدين بوتار
اذاعه موزاييك الخاصه ذات الانتشار الواسع
في تونس اوقف مديرها العام منذ ايام في
قضيه لا تعرف تفاصيلها الا بتصريح محاميته
التي اكدت ان من بين اسباب التحقيق معه
والخط التحريريه للمؤسسه هو تحدي كما اي
تحدي اخر نحن نعيشوه كتحدي للمهنه وكتحدي
للاذاعه كتحدي
لرساله رساله المهنه في الجهه المقابله
يبحث الرئيس قيس سعيد جميع الاتهامات
المتعلقه بانتهاك الحقوق والحريات
ومن بينها حريه الصحافه والتعبير وهل تمت
ملاحقه اي صحفي من اجل عملا يتعلق
بالصحافه
للاسف
اكاذيب
واراجيف يثير المرسوم الرئاسي المتعلق
بمكافحه الجرائم المتصله بانظمه المعلومات
والاتصال مخاوف جديه من اطراف عده نظرا
الى تضمنه عقوبات زجريه قاسيه
ويتنزل وفق منتقديه في اطار الطريق الرسمي
على الصحفيين والناشطين
تسر نقابه الصحفيين التونسيين على مواصله
تحركاتها دفاعا عن الحقوق والحريات
وتصديا لما تعتبره خطرا دائما يستهدف مهنه
الصحافه
وتساندها في ذلك منظمات حقوقيه ومدنيه في
وقت تعد فيه السلطات نفسها ضامنه لحريه
الراي والتعبير سيف الدين الجزيره
تونس
[موسيقى]
اتابع بشان الاوكراني حيث تركزت المعارك
في الساعه الماضيه في جبهه بخموت شرقيه
البلاد بينما تعرضت مناطق في مقاطعه خركيف
لهجوم روسيا بالصواريخ والمسيرات وفيما
قالت المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان حزمه العقوبات
العاشره على روسيا ستقدم اجراءات جديده
لمنع التحايل وصل وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي الى العاصمه كيا في اول زياره
لوزير اسرائيلي منذ دلاع الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا قبل عام
لا حسم قريبا في بخموت لكن المدينه
الواقعه شماليه مقاطعه دونسك في شرق
اوكرانيا ما تزال اسخن جبهات القتال قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه اعلنت ان 15 قريه في
محيط بخموت تعرضت خلال الساعات الماضيه
لقصف روسي شديد وعلى الجانب الاخر اقر
قائد ميليشيا فاجن التي تقود الهجوم على
المدينه بصعوبات ميدانيه امام مقاتليه
مرجحا السيطره على بخموت في اذار مارس
المقبل او نيسان ابريل ذلك يعني اخفاق
الحمله العسكريه الروسيه المكثفه في
الاسابيع الاخيره في تحقيق انتصار حاسم في
بخموت قبل الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
على اوكرانيا
وهذه خار كيف في الشرق الاوكراني ايضا
تعرضت فجرا لهجوم روسي بصواريخ اس 300
وطائرات مسيره اصاب اكثر من 20 بلده
ومدينه في المقاطعه وادى الى حرائق واضرار
واسعه في المنازل والمباني وفق تاكيد
اوكرانيا التي قالت ان قواتها اسقطت نصف
عدد الصواريخ المهاجمه تلك الهجمات وصفها
بيان من الاتحاد الاوروبي بالارهاب
المنهجي ضد اوكرانيا وشعبها وتعهد البيان
بمحاسبه المتورطين فيها الاتحاد اعلن ايضا
من خلال المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان حزمه
العقوبات العاشره على روسيا ستقر اجراءات
جديده لمنع الالتفاف عليها وتعهدت
المفوضيه بتعقب الذين يحاولون اخفاء
اصولهم او بيعها هربا من العقوبات كما
تعهدت بامكانيه
الاصول الروسيه المجمده في اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا على الصعيد السياسي يتعزز الدعم
الدبلوماسي فبعد عام على الحرب وللمره
الاولى وصلها وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
ايلي كوهين اكد كوهين دعم وحده اراضي
اوكرانيا وسيادتها وتعهد بالمساعده
والشراكه في اعاده اعمارها كما اعاد فتح
السفاره الاسرائيليه في كييف لكن من غير
المؤكد ان تبدد الزياره غضب اوكرانيا
المتراكم من تليابيب لتقاعسها عن الدعم
العسكري طوال عام كامل من الحرب بدعوى
البقاء على الحياد
علينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء دويري طبعا
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا اخذ
حيزا كبيرا من الموضوع
الاوكراني لفتنه قبل فتره تصريح لجذب
بوريل مفوض السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي يقول بالسياسه طبعا يقول بانه
للمره الاولى الكفه ليست في صالح اوكرانيا
كيف يمكن اسقاط هذا على ارض الواقع على
ساحه المعركه لواء دويري يعني في البدايه
دعني اؤكد على ما قاله لانه هناك عوامل
عده ادت الى ان يقدم هذا التصريح اولا حجم
القوه الان التقارير متباينه هناك كان
تعبئه جزئيه 300 الف تقارير اشارت ان
الدعوه كانت لخمس مئه الف وليس 300 الف
هناك تقارير تقول ان حجم القوات الموجود
في
شرق اوكر انيا الان هو ضعف حجم القوه التي
بدات العمليات في 24 شباط الماضي من العام
الماضي هذه النقطه رقم واحد النقطه رقم
اثنين
الانسحاب من خرسهم مكن القوات الروسيه ان
تنقل جزء من هذه القوات
وتوظيفها في منطقه الشرق دومباس
الامر الثالث دخول باخمه على الخط
وسيطرته على سوليدار
وقيادتها للعمليات من الاتجاه الشمالي وهو
الاخطر قدم دعما للجيش
تعديلات
جوهريه على طريقه اداره المعركه حيث اصبحت
الان هناك اكثر من نمط مستخدم فاقنر تقاتل
بطريقه معينه تمثل راس الحربه تتبنى
المناوره المحدود الصغيره وعمليات التجاوز
والسيطره على طرق المواصلات لقطع
الامدادات فيما الجيش الروسي لانه توفرت
القوى البشريه الكامله الكافيه بدا يستخدم
ما يطلق عليه الموجات البشريه
المتلاحقه ضبابيه الجبهه الشماليه مع
بيلاروسيا
اجبرت القوات الاوكرانيه على الاحتفاظ
بجزء ليس يسير من حجمها الجيش الاوكراني
لمراقبه تلك الجبهه والنقطه الاخيره
تاخر وصول الاسلحه اللازمه لهكذا نوع من
العمليات واقصد تحديدا صواريخ بعيده المدى
والدبابات هذا بالمجمل ادى الى انتقال
المبادئه من الجانب الاوكراني الى الجانب
الروسي بدقيقه واحده لو سمحت استراتيجيا
ماذا تقرا
باول زياره لوزير اسرائيلي الى كياف
باقتدار لو سمحت يعني الان هي لعبه خطيره
لانه اسرائيل بحاجه الى التعاون الروسي في
تنفيذ ضرباتها داخل سوريا
لتعقب
الميليشيات الايرانيه ونقل الاسلحه الى
حزب الله ولكن يبدو ان
لن تقدم الكثير لن تقدم القبه الحديديه
ستقدم دعما محدودا سهلت نقل الاسلحه
الامريكيه من المستودعات التي في داخل
اسرائيل اذا سيبقى اطار التعاون محدود
ولكن لن تقدم اسلحه فتاكه شكرا اللواء
فايز الدويري في عمان
[موسيقى]
في العاصمه الاثيوبيه اديس ابابا اعمال
المجلس التنفيذي للاتحاد الافريقي لبحث
التوافق بشان جدول الاعمال والقارات التي
سترفع لقمه الرؤساء الافارقه المقرره يومي
السبت والاحد المقبلين وبحث اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه الاستعداد والتحضير للقمم
الجانبيه التي ستعقد اليوم الجمعه والتي
ستناقش قضايا امنيه في القاره من بينها
الملف الليبي اضافه الى اصلاح مجلس الامن
الدولي وحصول القاره على مقعدين دائمين
فيه
الوجود الروسي في القاره الافريقيه
والنفوذ الدولي هناك كان حاضرا على هامش
الاجتماعات حيث قال وزير خارجيه مالي عبد
الله جيوب للجزيره ان لبلاده حريه اختيار
شركائها الخارجيين وذلك في تعليق على
انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه من مالي والوجود
الروسي في بلاده
الامر بسيط بالنسبه لنا بحسب ما قال رئيس
مالي لدينا ثلاث قواعد ذهبيه لتفاعلنا مع
المجتمع الدولي اولا احترام سيادتنا
واحترام خيارنا الاستراتيجي الذي تقوم به
حكومتنا في اختيار الشركاء والثالث هو
التاكد من مراعاه المصالح الحيويه لمالي
في جميع عمليات صنع القرار
جانبها اكدت وزيره خارجيه النرويج اهميه
التعاون الاوروبي مع دول افريقيه لمواجهه
ما وصفته بتدخل الروسي في شؤون القاره وفي
تصريحات للجزيره على هامش مشاركه بلادها
كمراقب في اجتماعات وزراء الخارجيه
الافارقه
اتهمت الوزيره ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه
بالقيام بدور في عدم استقرار الاوضاع
الامنيه بالقاره
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه تساهم بشكل مباشر في
عدم استقرار بعض الدول في هذه المنطقه
نعتقد انه يجب علينا تعزيز التعاون عندما
يتعلق الامر بالاحتياطات الامنيه ومواجهه
التهديدات الارهابيه لهذا اعتقد انه تجب
زياده التعاون بين الدول الاوروبيه والدول
الافريقيه لتفادي سيطره وتدخل روسيا في
افريقيا
في التقرير التالي نتعرف على شكل المنافسه
الاوروبيه الروسيه في افريقيا
على موقعها الجغرافي وثرواتها يتنافس
الكبار روسيا الصين الولايات المتحده
واقوى الدول الاوروبيه يحاول الجميع تامين
حركاته التجاريه في العالم عبر المياه
المشاطئه للقاره السمراء لكن الجميع كذلك
يسعى لاستغلال حاجات هذه القاره لتثبيت
نفوذ عسكري طويل الامد يعزز التفوق
الجيوسياسي لكل طرف صحيح ان الاعين
الاجنبيه التفتت قديما الى افريقيا الا ان
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعادت الى الواجهه
عناوين المنافسه في العالم خصوصا المنافسه
الاوروبيه الروسيه في افريقيا
كانت فرنسا راس الحربه في الهيمنه
الاوروبيه على افريقيا سيطرت على نصف
القاره تقريبا بعد عام
1885 تقلصت هذه السيطره شيئا فشيئا منتصف
القرن الماضي امتلكت فرنسا 100 قاعده
عسكريه تقلصت الى سبع قواعد فقط وبدا هذا
الوجود يتلاشى حتى بات مهددا بالكامل رغم
ذلك تظل اوروبا حاضره في القاره في فبراير
من العام الماضي عقدت القمه السادسه بين
الاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي اعلنت حينها
خطه استثماريه على مدى سبع سنوات لا يزال
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحظى بالحصه الكبرى من
الشراكه التجاريه مع افريقيا اكثر من ثلث
التبادل التجاري الافريقي الخارجي
عين روسيا بصيره هنا في نوفمبر 2019
استضاف الرئيس بوتين اول قمه روسيه
افريقيه الهدف تامين صفقات تجاريه ومشاريع
للطاقه وعقود عسكريه كانت روسيا اكبر مصدر
للاسلحه في المنطقه تنامت هذه الصادرات
اربعه واربعين في المئه بين 2017
و21 تنامى معها الوجود العسكري الروسي في
القاره في ليبيا ومالي وافريقيا الوسطى
وبوركينا فاسو اعتمدت على ميليشيا فاجنا
الذراع العسكريه غير الرسميه لموسكو
الحديث يطول كثيرا عن الوجود الامريكي
والصيني والمنافسه
على مساحه النفوذ في القاره السمراء هكذا
يتزاحم الكبار على تثبيت اقدام في افريقيا
على المدى البعيد تتعالى الاصوات الشعبيه
برفض هذه المنافسه تم من يرى ان التواتر
الاجنبي على القاره لا يخدم الا مصالح
الدول الكبرى فحسب
لن نبتعد عن القاره الافريقيه حيث تؤدي
الحروب والنزاعات والكوارث هناك الى نزوح
ولجوء لعشرات ملايين الاشخاص واشارت
احصائيات صادره عن منظمات امميه العام
الماضي الى ان عدد النازحين واللاجئين
قصرا في افريقيا وصل الى 36 مليون شخص وهو
ما يعادل نحو
45% من النازحين في العالم
الحروب والنزاعات المشتعله في افريقيا
خلفت كثيرا من الضحايا فاطمه حسن لخشيتها
من ان تقع ضحيه غليان الصدور بين قبيلتها
المتنازعه مع قبيله اخرى مجاوره لها لجات
مع عائلتها الى مخيم لاجئين في تشاد
ر على العوده اثناء الاشتباكات شاهدنا
كثيرا من الجثث منهم من قتل امام اعيننا
لا نستطيع العوده من بين نحو 100 الف لادن
لجا نحو عشره الاف الى هذا المخيم
عشرات المخيمات المشابهه يسكنها لاجئون من
افريقيا الوسطى ومن دارفور بالسودان ومن
نيجيريا
فالنزاعات المستمره في منطقه الساحل دفعت
ملايين الاشخاص الى اللجوء وجراء الحروب
في الكونغو الديمقراطيه وفي شرق افريقيا
بشكل عام فان اعداد النازحين واللاجئين
تحسب بالملايين
منظمات غير حكوميه شرعت في تنفيذ مشاريعه
تتيح للاجئين العمل في الزراعه في الاراضي
الممنوحه المجاوره للمخيم سيء جردي
يابلاسي اذا كان لدينا اليوم نازحون او
لاجئون فالسبب يعود الى مشكله معروفه لا
يمكن تحقيق التنميه دون سلام او تعارف
ولكي تتقدم افريقيا يجب علينا احلال
السلام توفر المخيمات مسكنا وماوى مؤقتا
لكن فرص الحياه وتطوير الذات وبناء
المستقبل لا تكاد تذكر يمكن القول ان
اللاجئين يكتفون بحلم احلال السلام في ربع
اوطانهم
والعوده الى ديارهم
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره من مخيم كلمباري
كندل غربيتشات
قال رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه لا توجد
مؤشرات على ان الاجسام الطائره التي تم
اسقاطها في الاجواء الامريكيه مرتبطه
ببرنامج تجسس للصين واضاف بيضا في كلمه ان
التقييم الحالي لاجهزه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه يشير الى ترجيح فرضيات ارتباط
هذه الاجسام الطائره بشركات خاصه او
مؤسسات بحثيه
اصدرت امرا باسقاط الاجسام الثلاثه بسبب
مخاطرها على الحركه الجويه وكذلك مخاطر
التجسسها على المنشات الحساسه تصرفنا
بدافع من الحذر يسعى الجيشين الامريكي
والكندي الى انتشال حطام هذه الاجسام حتى
نتمكن من معرفه المزيد عنها لا نعرف بعد
طبيعه الاجسام بالضبط لكن لا شيء في الوقت
الحالي يوحي بانها مرتبطه ببرنامج التجسس
الصيني او لدوله اخرى التقييم الحالي
للاجهزه الاستخباراتيه يشير الى ان هذه
الاجسام هي على الارجح مناطيض مرتبطه
بشركات خاصه ومؤسسات ترفيهيه او بحثيه
للدراسه الطقس او غيره
[موسيقى]
تحاول ان نفهم اكثر تنضم الينا من واشنطن
السيده لينزيمورن الضابطه السابقه في
وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
صيدلنزي
هل من دلالات
لتبرئه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الصين من
هذه الاجسام التي اسقطتها السلطات
الامريكيه بعد ان اسقطت منطادا قالت بانه
تجسسي لصالح الصين
لا اعتقد ان الرئيس كان يحاول ارسال هذه
الرساله اعتقد ان الوضع الذي نواجهه الان
انه هناك
تدخلًا في اجواءنا من قبل منطاد تجسس
الصيني وما يحدث الان هو ان العمليه باتت
اكثر وضوحا واجهزه مراقبتنا بدات تلحظها
واصبحنا اكثر
حذرا الان وارسلنا اليهم رساله باننا
سنسقط اي جسم يحلق في اجواءنا ولن نقبل
ابدا بوجود ايه
مناطيل او اجسام اخرى ذا الطبيعه تجسسها
ربما كثير منها يكون حميدا ممكن يكون مجرد
مناطير الابحاث او اشياء لها علاقه
بالبيئه او مصالح تجاريه لكن على حال نحن
ناخذ اجراءات احترازيه اضافيه من باب
التحسب للمستقبل ومن دون طبعا يتم الان
بحث ركام المنطاد الذي اسقط للتاكد من
هويته يعني هو المنطاد الصيني هو الذي
اثار كل هذه القضيه الرئيس بايدن قال الان
باننا لا نعرف طبيعه هذه الاجسام عندما
عندما لا يعرف البيت الابيض طبيعه هذه
الاجسام ما الخطر الذي يمكن ان تشكله على
الامن القومي الامريكي في سماء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اذا
نعم سؤال وجيه للغايه نحن لا نستطيع ان
نجزم بانها لا تشكل خطرا على الامن القومي
ما لم نستطع استكمال دراسه ركان المنطاد
الذي اسقط وما كانت امكانياته حقيقه من
دون ذلك لا نستطيع تقييم هل هناك
تهديد او لا وان كان هناك تهديد ماذا
خطورته في بشكل واقعي يجب ان نقول ان اي
جسم يطير في الاجواء يثير القلق ليس من
الناحيه النفسيه لكن ايضا من قبل ايه
التداعيات حقيقيه وواقعيه ما تعلمناه من
مساله المنطاد الصيني لا ندري بعد اوروبا
ما سنقوم نحن ايضا بشان عمليات من هذا
النوع للجمع معلومات استخباريه من الجو
ولكن طبعا يجب ان نضمن ايضا بان مناطير او
اجسام طائره من بلدان اخرى لا تخترق
اجوائنا ايضا هي الصين اصلا اتهمت
الولايات المتحده بانها تطير ايضا مناطيد
في في سمائها هل هل هذا يعني بان المنطاد
الصيني استطاع فعلا ان يجمع معلومات
استخباراتيه عن مناطق في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
طبعا
اي نوع من المعلومات
الاستخباريه ان كان الحصل على هؤلاء هو
فوق مستوى معلوماتي انا فلا استطيع ان
اجذب لكن من باب التخمين نقول ان في
الفتره القصيره التي قضاها في الاجواء
الامريكيه ربما لن يكون مهما وقد لا يشكل
تهديد الامن القومي مقارنه بالتكتيكات
الاخرى التي تستخدمها الصين لجمع
المعلومات تستقبال عن عن الوقت المتحده
فهي كثيره ومعقده ومركبه تجعلنا نقلق
بشانها اكثر من المنطاد لكن شكرا مع ذلك
نقول من الناحيه النفسيه كان له تاثير
وطبعا
هذا يقلق الشعب الامريكي والرئيس الامريكي
امراه اجواء شكرا لك
الضابطه السابقه في وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه في واشنطن شكرا لك
الان الى اخبار الرياضه مع معز بولحيه